ja und ich freue mich sehr über diese
einladung das sind auch tolle
veranstaltungen das hier lehrende
zusammenkommen auch über die disziplinen
hinweg und über lehre sprechen und
darüber reflektieren letztendlich ist es
ja auch genau das was herr lesch betont
hat es geht eigentlich um diese
verliebtheit ja in seine eigene
tätigkeit diese zu kultivieren und auch
das ist etwas was natürlich wieder uns
zurück führt zu humboldt der dieses
moment eigentlich der wissenschaft
gleich in den vordergrund stellt wenn er
zum beispiel über das
universitätsstudium sagt es geht um das
innere streben zur wissenschaft und
forschung her also eine sehnsucht sogar
sich zu wissenschaft zu erheben
und ja diese sprache sie klingt so ein
bisschen eben nach romantischer
wissenschaft und ich freue mich
eigentlich dass es auch in diesen
kreisen diese sprache noch gibt es
teilweise neigt dann die
hochschuldidaktik dazu dass viel viel
nüchterner auszudrücken zum beispiel der
mich einfach zu sagen es geht um einen
lernen im format der forschung
das greife ich aber trotzdem mal auf
weil ich frage was ist denn das format
der forschung gibt das auch nur ein
format oder gibt es mehrere
berühmt sind einteilung zum beispiel von
donald stokes der mit dem pastörs
quadranten zum beispiel sagte es gibt
also einmal diese grundlagenforschung
und dann gibt es anwendungsforschung ja
ja und wie das dann in seiner schönen
tabelle ist dann sagt dana es gibt auch
so was wie nutzen inspirierte
grundlagenforschung also eigene
mischform ja dann hätten wir drei
formate
aber reicht das überhaupt wenn ich mich
umschaue
da gibt es zum beispiel größte
anlagen technologische anlagen ein
vortrag vorher hatte auch schon darauf
abgezielt naturwissenschaftliche
forschung ist bei ihrem vortrag ist
verdammt teuer ganz genau
und überhaupt nicht mit dem vergleichbar
was wir in sozialwissenschaften
geisteswissenschaften machen dann könnte
man sich fragen gibt die technologie
quasi uns vor was eigentlich forschung
ist
ich möchte die frage ein bisschen anders
formulieren und fragen ob denn die
forschung ein modell ist und zwar ein
modell für die lehre forschung und lehre
sind zwei seiten der wissenschaft
insofern könnte man auch jetzt erstmal
einführen ist die forschung eigentlich
ein modell für die wissenschaft und dann
für lehre und lernen also so formuliert
denn modelle sind nicht nur abbildungen
von etwas sondern modelle haben auch
handlungs leitenden charakter sie werden
häufig auch dafür gemacht dass man mit
ihnen experimentieren kann dass man
etwas ausprobieren kann
und insofern könnte man erstmal auch
sagen
forschung ist ein modell von
wissenschaft und dann wieder ein modell
für lehren und lernen
ich werde in dem vortrag das ganze auch
noch etwas anders thematisieren nämlich
mal von der anderen seite herum was ist
denn lernen für ein modell das jetzt
aber erstmal nur angedeutet in meinen
forschungsgebiet sie haben ja eben schon
gehört habe ich relativ viele
unterschiedliche fragen also vom
arbeitsmarkt herkommend berufspädagogik
wo ich promoviert habe psychologische
fragen und
je mehr ich mich mit der
forschungsorientierten lehre beschäftige
umso mehr kommen eigentlich die ganzen
fragen der wissenschaftsforschung auch
zum tragen und ein
wissenschaftstheoretiker aus den usa hat
zum beispiel gesagt wir haben also vor
allen dingen auch verschiedene modelle
von dem was erkenntnis eigentlich
ausmacht was die erkenntnis erzeugung
ausmacht und auf diese frage möchte ich
erst mal eingehen denn ja man könnte so
beschreiben
manche sagen das sind unterschiedliche
fachkulturen amberg und ich habe gerade
schon versprochen es gibt einen schönen
witz es gibt verschiedene willst du
natürlich über die verschiedenen
fachkulturen und einer knüpft an das an
was wir auch eben schon zur mathematik
diskutiert haben
stellen sie sich eine szene vor
es sitzen drei wissenschaftler auf einer
bank das ist ein physiker ein biologe
und ein mathematiker und von dort
beobachten sie ein haus und sie sehen
wie zwei leute in dieses haus hinein
gehen und dann nach einer weile kommen
drei leute heraus der physiker sagt da
war meine erste messung wohlig ganz
richtig sagt der biologe ach nein die
haben sich nur vermehrt und der
mathematiker sagt wenn jetzt noch einer
rein geht dann ist das haus leer
nicht also wir sehen fachkulturen
blicken auf ihren gegenstand sehr sehr
unterschiedlich und die
wissenschaftstheorie nimmt natürlich
genau diese sache in den blick als frage
wie unterschiedlich produzieren
eigentlich wissenschaftler ihre
erkenntnisse und die
wissenschaftstheorie ein us
amerikanischer wissenschaftler don
cheadle sagte zum beispiel es gab ein
sehr sehr einschlägiges modell dafür wie
wissen erzeugt wird die camera obscura
in einem aufsatz mit dem titel art
proceeds science also die kunst kommt
sozusagen vor der wissenschaft sagt er
ja im grunde müssen sogar diese
tätigkeiten also die knowledge
production activities kulturell erst
entwickelt sein bevor sie die
wissenschaft befruchten und die
wissenschaft hat also zunächst die
camera obscura noch nicht für sich
entdeckt sondern erst nachdem also die
kunst dieses als wunderbares instrument
gesehen hat hier sehen sie einen
kupferstich von dürer der hier eine
szene darstellt wo jemand eine laute mit
hilfe einer camera obscura technik
sozusagen in ihren genauen proportionen
abbildet ronny gesagt okay man sieht das
sind sozusagen verschiedene stile oder
ist erst mal überhaupt einen stil wie
wissen produziert wird ein wissensspiel
und vielleicht kennen sie auch den
wissenschaftstheoretiker ludwig fleck
der von einem denkstil spricht ganz
ähnlich eigentlich und damit eigentlich
sehr einschlägig auch gezeigt hat wissen
wird nicht einfach nur erzeugt im sinne
von a wie
decken irgendetwas sondern seine
provokative these war
fakten werden entwickelt sie entstehen
auf dem hintergrund von bestimmten
forschungspraxis dort zum beispiel sagt
dana ja auch für unsere gegenwart hat
dieses modell entsprechend ausgedient
weil wir computer technologien einsetzen
und computertechnologien etwas ganz
anderes machen computertechnologien sind
diejenigen ja er nennt das sogar
systemische maschinen oder bis
theologische maschinen die eine riesen
datenmenge verrechnen können woher
kommen die daten sie kommen aus
verschiedenen mess vorgängen und auch
das ist dann entsprechend kritik
innerhalb der wissenschaftstheorie dass
wir anders als eben die camera obscura
wo sie wirklich ganz genau sehen können
dass ein punkt in der wirklichkeit der
beleuchtet wird und wo das licht dann
durch die kleine öffnung zeigt noch mal
eben hier den anderen apparat dass jeder
punkt aus der wirklichkeit einen
maßstabsgetreuen referenzpunkt auf der
abbild seite hat und das ginge mit den
messdaten in den computer
verarbeitungsprozessen verloren
ich habe zum beispiel einen radiologen
mal gesprochen in einem
vollautomatisierten krankenhaus in oslo
der mir erzählte dass es da natürlich
also die neuesten technologischen
standards gibt und man benutzt teilweise
3d bilder die die knochenbrüche besser
anzeigen könnten wäre das abgelehnt und
gesagt nee ich weiß dass dahinter eine
simulation steht und ich erkenne besser
durch meine erfahrung wenn ich auch nur
eine kleine andeutung sehe von einem
kleinen feinen knochen riss
er kenne ich das besser weil die
computerprogramme so etwas feines
übergehen und stattdessen lieber schauen
dass es eine tolle simulation gibt so
dass ich dann eine 3d abbildung habe
also er vertraute dieser technologie auf
diesem hintergrund nicht aber
nichtsdestotrotz also wir können uns
heutzutage klimaforschung nicht ohne
simulation modellierung und so weiter
vorstellen
diese großen projekte können ohne diese
technologie nicht gemacht werden und wir
geben uns quasi ein format von forschung
vor
zunächst da auch eine
wissenschaftstheoretiker oder wissens
soziologin hat sich mit der frage
beschäftigt wie unterschiedlich die
wissenschaften vorgehen hier ein schönes
beispiel
sie sehen da im hintergrund einen
hirnforscher david ferrer im neunzehnten
jahrhundert berühmt wurde weil er ein
modell des gehirns geschaffen hat was
bislang noch nicht existierte da hat man
hirne vor allen dingen gar nicht richtig
untersuchen können natürlich an toten
menschen aber was er gemacht hat war er
hat offen
also es ist nicht besonders schön aber
er hat natürlich als lebendige objekte
studiert und daraus dann ein modell des
gehirns entwickelt
dieses modell wurde lange zeit benutzt
obwohl man aus heutiger sicht sagen muss
das ist ungefähr so wie wenn ich in
london unterwegs bin und einen stadtplan
von paris mitgenommen habe ja es ist im
grunde überhaupt nicht aussagekräftig
und dennoch in den suchprozess in der
wissenschaft hat dieses eine
orientierungsfunktion gehabt und
vielleicht kann man diesen begriff der
innovation dafür auch tatsächlich
übertragen den wir vorhin gehört haben
also dass man einfach eine inspiration
hat
an den problemen weiter zu arbeiten aber
passiert sehen ist dass wir also
überhaupt keine eindeutigen modelle
haben von dem was wissenschaft ist und
selbst die wissenschaft ist sich nicht
einig darüber dass richtige wissenschaft
ist wie sollten wir also dann dahin
kommen und sagen das ist jetzt ein
modell für unsere lehre für unser lernen
es gibt in der lehr lernforschung
dennoch natürlich versuche irgendetwas
modellhaft auch zu beschreiben was wir
verwenden können um leere zu gestalten
und dabei versuchen viele einfach die
inhaltlichen fragen auszublenden und
erstmal rein formal an die sache
heranzugehen hier gibt es zum beispiel
ein phasen modell was an die definition
sozusagen auch sich anlehnen könnte von
huber dass wir also einen kompletten
forschungsprozess den studierenden ja
zumuten durchaus zumuten und zwar in
diesen phasen hier die also an john
dewey angelehnt sind die phase der im
agents der vermutung der konzeption dann
die untersuchung dann möglicherweise
eine entdeckung die kritische phase
was habe ich da eigentlich gemacht auch
das bewerten und dann der transfer
ich habe aber gerade deswegen weil mir
das als phasen modell zu sehr auf eine
formale seite hin gebogen ist doch die
frage gestellt gibt es da nicht noch
etwas anderes an modellen gibt es nicht
noch ein modell was sich auch
tatsächlich mit der inhaltlichen seite
der forschung beschäftigt und bin dann
auf die suche gegangen und ich habe
einen text gefunden von hartmut von
hentig übrigens vorgänger von ludwig
huber der zur wissenschaft didaktik
gearbeitet hat und interessanterweise
eben eine genaue umkehrung dessen
gemacht hat was ich eben vorformuliert
habe ist die forschung ein modell für
die wissenschaft und von der
wissenschaft und dann für die lehre
er sieht es genau umgekehrt und ich
deswegen muss ich hier ein skript haben
ich habe ihnen dazu auch die zitate
mitgebracht und zwar sagte er 1969 in
einem vortrag
er argumentierte wissenschaft sei auf
lern theorie angewiesen
genauer auf eine koordinierung von sach
struktur in der sich wissen darstellt
und lern struktur in der wissen
aufgenommen wird wenn sie ihren eigenen
fortschritt gewachsen bleiben will
so schauen wir uns das doch mal genauer
noch an er argumentierte also genau
umgekehrt und weiter noch mal aus dem
vortrag
ich will doch ein bisschen den kontext
dieses vortrags auch mit einholen
er sagt wird die wissenschaft so fragt
man füglich der objektiven wahrheit und
kritik der gesellschaft weiter dienen
können wenn sie zugleich in den dienst
pragmatischer und zudem unter geortet
da also bei ihr und ökonomisch
untergebrachter und weitgehend politisch
bestimmte aufgaben genommen wird wie
kommt er eigentlich jetzt da auf diese
frage ja der politischen bestimmungen
man wird erstaunt sein vor 50 jahren
kommen genau die themen auf die heute
harald lesch schon angesprochen hat die
ökonomisierung kommt auf als problem
es kommt auch die expansion auf die
vermassung der universitäten die
bedrohte freiheit von wissenschaft
ich weiß nicht ob sie noch in erinnerung
haben anfang des jahres warnte sogar die
europäischen rektorenkonferenz davor
dass wir hier also die freiheit in der
wissenschaft bedroht sehen müssen
außerdem ganz diverse erwartungen daran
was jetzt die wissenschaftliche
ausbildung an land nicht mehr nur für
die wissenschaft soll ausgebildet werden
sondern berufsorientiert usw
wirtschaftliche probleme die
ökologischen probleme alles soll jetzt
von den universitäten ausgelöst werden
gelöst werden und auch das klingt alles
schon in diesem vortrag von 1969 an
wieso kommt also jetzt nun von hentig
auf die idee dass es notwendig ist dass
die wissenschaft sich erst mal am modell
des lernens ausrichtet diese frage lässt
sich also eigentlich erst mal nur
beantworten wenn man darüber spricht was
man denn unter lernen versteht
hentig hielt zum beispiel diese
förderung von ryan intrinsisch
motivierte lernen für pure ideologie
auch kritisierte er diese schon damals
begonnene vermessung von lehrern praxen
auch als ein problem als gegenteil der
aufklärung
stattdessen seien zu erkennen dass es
ein notwendiges verhältnis zwischen
erkenntnis und lernen oder genauer
zwischen wissens struktur und lern
struktur geben
so seien wissenschaft das verfahren
durch das ich nämlich sichern möchte
dass du siehst was auch ich sehe ja das
war auch schon von harald lesch genau
dieses ding erst wenn ich in der lehre
auch zb das formuliert habe und dass
genau abgeprüft habe dann sehe ich dass
genau das heißt also hartmut von hentig
will ganz klar herausstellen
wissenschaft ist immer schon angewiesen
darauf auf die mitteilung auf die
verständlichkeit
dann kommt erst überhaupt das gefühl von
gewissheiten nämlich auf zusammenhang
und vollständigkeit
dann natürlich schon auch auf
spezialisierung aber spezialisierung als
solches funktioniert eigentlich gar
nicht was habe ich wenn ich nur ein
einzelnes detail irgendwo sehen wir
vielleicht mal die klimaforschung wieder
als beispiel
sie nehmen irgendeine messung ja die ich
hoch spezialisiert gewonnen habe und sie
wissen noch gar nichts bringt gar nichts
ja erst dann wenn ich irgendein detail
ein datum der sich da erhoben habe
einordnen kann
erst dann weiß ich irgendetwas und das
ist übrigens auch überhaupt diese ganze
frage von ganzheitlichkeit
ganzheitlichkeit meint nicht ich muss
alles sehen
das ist es gar nicht ganzheitlichkeit
ist eine frage ob ich wenn ich eine
information bekomme oder irgendeine form
von daten erhoben habe dass ich weiß wo
ich sie einordnen muss sonst sehe ich
das gar nicht und das ist natürlich die
frage auch eben verfügbarkeit von wissen
die dabei reinspielt kontinuität und so
weiter so hartmut von hentig ist also
letztendlich einer der sich auch in die
tradition von
einreiht denn was steht bei kant da
steht die große wende dass die kriterien
die für die objektivität von
wissenschaft verbürgen nicht auf der
objekt seite liegen sondern auf der
seite des erkenntnisses objektes also in
dieser hinsicht geht es darum zu sagen
forschen ist erstmal nur in soweit dann
ein modell von wissenschaft als wir hier
inter subjektivität herstellen können
und dann kann ich auch sagen aha also
kommt jetzt das modell von das lernen
ist ein modell von denkspielen
denkspielen ausbilden kognitive prozesse
durchführen und so weiter und dann kann
das tatsächlich überführt werden in ein
modell für die wissens entwicklung für
das forschen
allerdings müssen wir natürlich mit
überlegen wenn ich es so formulieren
also eine frage dessen ich will es noch
mal auf einen schönen satz bringen also
sag mir was wissenschaft tut und ich
leite dann daraus etwas für das
wissenschaftliche lernen wichtig ist
dann ist das eine relativ einseitige
betrachtung ok jedoch was macht jetzt
das umgekehrte modell sag mir was man
erlernen kann überhaupt und ich weiß was
in der wissenschaft möglich ist meines
erachtens auch ein relativ einseitiger
weg
nur wenn ich dieses modell jetzt in eine
verbindung tatsächlich bringe dann kann
ich darüber hinaus gehen und vor allen
dingen kann ich dann nicht nur formal
über die frage von wissenschaft sprechen
sondern ich kann auch den inhaltlichen
die inhaltliche seite mit einbeziehen
ich brauche also ein modell einer sich
im fluss befindlichen wissenschaft und
gleichzeitig auch ein modell des lernens
was in diesem fluss steht jetzt komme
ich an einen punkt wo ich sage hier
brauche ich ein neues modell
und dieses neue modell muss auch
verstehen was beim lernen nämlich
passiert wir haben eben einen
wunderschönen vortrag gehört über solche
kreativen prozesse die manchmal gar
nicht bewusst oder zumindest nicht schon
vorgeplant sind sondern sie entstehen
plötzlich und diesen prozess
den kann man auch in der wissenschaft
nennen als das brechen mit einer schon
bestehenden form der wissens erzeugung
der wissenschaftstheoretiker kasten
basler hat es nämlich genau so
bezeichnet es ist der psychologische
bruch den wir immer wieder in den
wissenschaften beobachten können nicht
in jedem moment aber zumindest an
verschiedenen punkten wo eine bestimmte
wissens entwicklung an einem punkt
gekommen ist wo sie nicht weiterarbeiten
kann
das war zum beispiel in der physik der
fall als man mit der quantenmechanik
märkte ob da sind plötzlich ganz andere
prozesse am werk die kann ich mit dem
was ich vorher auch mit den kategorien
die kant für apriori kategorien gehalten
hat nämlich raum und zeit
die kann ich damit gar nicht mehr fassen
ich muss diese begriffe umarbeiten ich
muss auf ein ganz anderes terrain kommen
mit dem kann ich erst wieder neu
erklären
was überhaupt quantenmechanik ist so an
diesem möchte ich mich orientieren und
sagen ein neues modell ist zu schaffen
erstens wo ich verstehe forschen ist ein
praktischer prozess bei dem man den
erkenntnisstand einer wissenschaft
überschreiten kann
zweitens werden dazu geeignete
forschungs praxen gesucht das heißt also
bevor ich überhaupt erkenntnis suche
natürlich geht es mir immer darum
erkenntnis zu suchen aber häufig geht
das erst mal darüber dass ich überhaupt
frage habe ich möglicherweise eine
andere art forschung zu praktizieren
dass ich auf neue problemlösungen komme
und insofern kann ich das lernen hier
verorten als eines gibt diese schöne
formulierung aus der philosophie eine
einheit von erkennen und verändern
in dieser einheit geschieht dann das
lernen bei dem ganzen möchte ich mich
auch auf die psychologie noch mal
stützen die kognitionspsychologie von
diana die uns noch ein weiteres bild
gibt von dem was forschendes denken
heißt und was überhaupt die fähigkeit
aus psychologischer sicht ausmacht
wissenschaftlich zu denken
ich habe jetzt das ganze auf englisch
also im original zitiert ich übersetze
das ganz kurz mal also der die
wissenschaftlerin ist in der lage eine
theorie die er oder sie als richtig
ansieht bewusst zu formulieren
er oder sie weiß welche belege oder
hinweise diese theorie stützen oder
stützen könnten und welche ihr
widersprechen und c kann er oder sie
rechtfertigen warum diese koordination
zwischen den verfügbaren theorien und
den beweisstücken ihn sie veranlasst
haben jene theorie zu akzeptieren und
andere abzulehnen die ebenfalls ja auch
eine ecke
ehrung für dasselbe phänomen anzugeben
beanspruchen obwohl diese merkmale nicht
alle aspekte wissenschaftlichen denkens
enthalten sind diese fähigkeiten bei der
koordination von theorie und beweis oder
nachweis evidenz ist also nicht ein so
starker begriff aber dennoch besser mit
beweis zu übersetzen als mit einfach nur
evidenz dass evidenz geht gar nicht
sondern es geht ja um den nachweis ja
also empirische belege und so weiter die
koordination also von theorie und
nachweis oder b weiß sind die
wichtigsten allgemeinen fähigkeiten
welche das wissenschaftliche denken
definieren so wenn ich jetzt nun ein
modell entwickelt das dieses in den kern
eigentlich des ganzen erhebt so möchte
ich mit großem engagement zumindest auch
wieder zeigen dass genau in diesen
koordinierungs prozess brüche
beziehungsweise auch sprünge passieren
können
die bedeuten dass ich nicht mehr in dem
gleichen format oder im gleichen rahmen
bleibe sondern genau dieses durch den
inhalt sozusagen mit dem ich da nicht
ausländer setzte und den ich irgendwie
auf den begriff bringen möchte dass ich
genau das tue was ich dieses format
wiederum sprenge das habe ich hier in
konzentrischen kreisen versucht
anzudeuten die koordination von theorie
und beweis steht also hier im zentrum
des ganzen ist ausgangspunkt und wir
gehen mal davon aus dass jetzt auch eine
beliebige setzung dass zum beispiel
daten vorliegen vielleicht sind sie eben
wie auch zb bei ihnen als teil ihres
forschungsprozesses dass sie sagen okay
ich habe hier material können sie damit
arbeiten und so weiter sie werden
vielleicht einmal gegeben oder sie
liegen irgendwo vor
könnte aber auch sein dass natürlich
erstmal auch datenerhebungen passiert
jedenfalls jetzt kommt als genau dieser
koordinations prozess die frage auf habe
ich mit diesen daten eine möglichkeit
meine hypothesen zu beantworten auch
diese hypothesen können selbst
entwickelt sein oder auch von jemandem
dozentin dozent gesetzt sein
jedenfalls muss genau jetzt an dieser
stelle gefragt werden passt das
zueinander oder bräuchte ich nicht eher
andere daten oder vielleicht muss sich
auch überlegen ob ich andere hypothesen
benötige
denn mit den vorliegenden daten kann ich
sie nicht bearbeiten
so also hier fängt sozusagen eine
dynamik an eine dynamik ein problem das
ich studierenden durchaus zumuten kann
wenn sie aber dann an diese probleme
herangehen ist die nächste frage
aber wenn ich neue daten erheben oder
auch eine andere hypothese brauche wie
generiere ich die also brauche ich
wieder eine reflexion darüber was sich
für methoden habe welche theorien welche
begriffe adäquat sind und in dieser
reflexion kann man könnte natürlich
genau dasselbe wieder passieren dass
mich diese inhaltliche beschäftigung
wieder an den rand dessen führt was ich
als gegebenes format vorfinde
also ich entwickele eine kritik an den
methoden an den theorien also inklusive
der begriffe und wo kommen wir da hin
ich habe eben schon den denkstil erwähnt
von ludwig fleck der begriff des denk
steals wurde von thomas kuhn ich glaube
nicht verwandt mit jana kuhn aber auf
ähnlichen gebiet tätig übersetzt als das
paradigma der denkstil ist das paradigma
in dem ich forsche
und in diesem sinne kann auch die
beschäftigung wieder wenn ich mich mit
methoden und theorien kritisch
auseinandersetze dazu führen dass ich
merke die sind auf einem gebiet
entwickelt worden und dieses gebiet habe
ich schon längst überschritten
also muss ich anfangen über das
paradigma nachzudenken
übrigens etwas was sie nachvollziehen
können auch mit den modellen die ich
vorhin gezeigt habe das camera obscura
modell ist nach heutiger
wissenschaftstheorie ein überholtes
modell warum weil das an eine auffassung
von empirismus anknüpft wissenschaft
bräuchte sozusagen nur zu beobachten und
genau hinzuschauen und dann genau zu
messen
dann wäre schon alles okay aber die
heutige wissenschaft kann ihre objekte
fast gar nicht mehr einfach nur
beobachten
ja das ist das große problem wer hat
schon einen atom gesehen also die
objekte die gegenstände der forschung
geraten und sozusagen völlig aus dem
blickfeld oder wer hat den klimawandel
gesehen ja doch wir kriegen hier eine
ganze menge mit
von wegen dürre und so weiter aber auch
das ist natürlich nicht der begriff den
wissenschaften von klimawandel haben
oder denken sie an andere begriffe die
gesellschaft wer hat die gesellschaft
gesehen auch niemand ja also
konstruieren wir unseren gegenstand und
das heißt also ich muss anfangen über
das nachzudenken wie ich diesen
gegenstand theoretisch konstruiere
nichts geht mehr ohne theorie ok ich
komme auf den didaktischen prozess
zurück denken sie jetzt an diese
transformatorische bewegung die ich
ihnen eben aufgezeigt habe nochmal
es ist hier auch wieder durch die kreise
angedeutet aber jetzt wirklich in den
vordergrund die lehr lern beziehung
mir geht es jetzt darum ganz grob erst
mal zu sagen okay das ist alles etwas
was auch in unseren beziehungen zu
studierenden eine rolle spielt ich kann
das zwar nicht einfach so einmal so
erzählen und vermitteln und sagen so ist
es sondern ich bin vor allen dingen
jemand der als vorbild hier dient und
eine rolle einnimmt und das den
studierenden zeigt wie bin ich
eigentlich jemand erforscht und was
machen studierende ganz grob sie
identifizieren sich entweder und sagen
okay das war es jemand davor lebt ist
tatsächlich für mich vorbildhaft und
finden das als erstrebenswert auch nur
dann können wir darauf hoffen dass zum
beispiel diese ganzen interessen sich
entwickeln können
diwi notwendigerweise brauchen damit
tiefen verarbeitung geschieht und so
weiter es kann aber auch sein dass
studierende sich nicht damit
identifizieren
das ist nicht unbedingt fürs lernen
grundsätzlich schlecht
auch in der auseinandersetzung also
abstoßung kann ja gelernt werden ich
will nur zumindest sagen
in dem moment wo studierende genau
dieser persönlichen beziehung sind
greifen sie eigentlich auf erfahrungen
zu
die gar nicht mehr ganz persönlicher art
sind die erfahrungen um die es in der
wissenschaft geht sind über individuelle
erfahrungen also wie gesagt ein atom ist
auch nichts was ich persönlich
erforschen kann ja ich kann es nur über
die wissenschaft und die wissenschaft
ist eine scientific community
sie ist eine gemeinschaft die
instrumente braucht die große anlage
braucht um solche dinge zu erforschen
insofern ist dieser ganze prozess ein
prozess den ich als inkulturation
bezeichne und in diesem end kultur
aktions prozess können wir jetzt nun
zwei bewegungen zumindest auch wieder
ganz grob skizzieren und zwar eine
verwissenschaftlichung in dem sinne dass
wir auf eine wissens entwicklung hin
gehen die versucht gültige erkenntnisse
zu produzieren und das mit dieser
gültigkeit auch einher geht dass zum
beispiel in der gesellschaft diese werte
eine rolle spielen ja also wenn die
klimaforschung sagt das und das sind
unsere berechnungen dass und das sind
notwendige maßnahmen um den klimawandel
aufzuhalten
dann ist das und das in der politik
erforderlich ja das ist eine art und
weise wie verwissenschaftlichung der
gesellschaft passiert erkenntnisse
werden als gültig wahrgenommen und sie
werden auch teil dessen was in der
gesellschaft als gültige praxis dann
angesehen wird
dies ist also eine dynamik an der
studierende partizipieren können das
problem ist oder nee was heißt das
problem es gibt zumindest eine andere
seite die ich eben auch skizziert habe
und die für die wissenschaft mindestens
genauso wichtig ist wie die
verwissenschaftlichung als
institutionalisieren und das ist genau
die andere seite wissenschaft als kritik
als lebendige kritik als eine kritik die
eine unabhängigkeit hat von der auch
harald lesch heute gesprochen hat eine
unabhängigkeit sagen zu können das ist
richtig und das ist falsch
das macht die wissenschaft
sie versucht gültige erkenntnisse wahre
erkenntnis zu tage zu fördern
auch wenn wir natürlich da nie einen
endpunkt sehen können und nie endgültig
wissen was wahr ist aber es ist eben
auch der teil dessen was wissenschaft
mit macht und das was ich ihnen jetzt
als vielleicht als open question auch
mitgeben möchte ist die frage wie
verhalten sich diese beiden seiten der
wissenschaft im leeren zueinander
gerade studierende werden durch die
kritik die notwendiges element jeder
wissenschaft ist doch durchaus mit
verunsichert viel leichter ist es also
sich auf die seite zu stellen und zu
sagen ich gucke nur danach dass die
wissenschaft sozusagen zu ihrer geltung
kommt innerhalb der gesellschaft dass
sie da hin kommt dass sie anerkannt wird
für gültige erkenntnisse
ja denn damit gehen einher auch ganz
viele prozesse der stabilisierung
verstetigung karrieren können darauf
aufgebaut werden aber auf der kritik
werden die karriere nicht unbedingt
aufgebaut und deswegen ist die kritik
und das wissen die studierenden übrigens
auch nicht nur eine einfache übung
sondern es ist tatsächlich etwas was sie
als ganze person mit verlangt
also das ist die frage wie verhält sich
jetzt dieses beides innerhalb der lehre
zueinander
die wissenschaft braucht um wirklich
auch ein nachwuchs zu haben der die
wissenschaft lebendig behält und nicht
nur darauf achtet dass sie zu
exzellenzinitiativen und so weiter eine
gute figur macht sondern nein die
wissenschaft selber als wissens
erzeugung als praxis der wissens
erzeugung wenn diese lebendig gehalten
werden muss dann brauchen wir auch genau
dieses wo wir den das moment der kritik
mit integrieren
wie gesagt und das ist etwas was mit
dazu beiträgt dass wir zukünftig eine
wirkliche wissenschaftler haben sonst
wird das ganze zu einer staffage wenn
wir da rauskommen wollen also das ist
die große frage wie verhält sich das
zueinander schaffen wir es auch da
vorbilder zu sein wie die
identifikations momente zu schaffen wo
studierende sagen das lohnt sich auch
das risiko einzugehen dass ich
möglicherweise hier nicht einfach zu
einer karriere komme sondern es riskiere
auch vor kollegen oder anderen
wissenschaftlern zu stehen und zu sagen
das muss kritisiert werden weil
denken sie darüber nach ich bedanke mich
für die aufmerksamkeit und hier sind
noch kurze hinweise auch durch die
bildquellen her genommen haben vielen
dank